écoutez
1 hélène françois hélène cce
je crois que c'est à nous voilà je suis
sur scène là tu meures jour elle me
rejoins pas écouté je vais en profiter
pour une fois que je suis tout seul sur
scène je suis bien là j'ai mon petit
micro le public
merci c'est gentil voilà c'est moi qui
suis sur scène c'est moi qui ai mes
crocs c'est moi qui parle vous m'écoutez
bon et je commence oui mais non en fait
je trouve que c'est pas une bonne idée
on s'est un peu place puis ça me
ressemble pas trop fins et merci je sens
pas du tout qu'ils en pensent
on va faire ça quand on fait d'habitude
avec un peu plus de relief
chez d'accord allez c'est d'après midi
vous avez écouté des speakers qui ont
été choisies pour leurs idées qui
peuvent changer le monde
vous avez été là ils sont montés sur
scène les avait écoutés je voulais
réécoute ray sans doute c'est fabuleux
de prendre la parole c'est un peu
impressionnant mais c'est fabuleux
mais en même temps vous tout cela vous
avez des idées nous aussi on en a tous
des idées est ce que c'est vraiment le
plus important ce qui est important
peut-être c'est quand même de faire ils
le faire comme alice alice du aussi qu'
on l'a vu il lui arrive des choses toute
sa vie mais elle se laisse pas se laisse
pas faire justement elles se laissent
pas mettre dans des cases à les cases en
personne les mettre dans des cases
personnes mais soyons honnêtes on met
tout le monde
facilement dans des cases nous aussi
quand on rencontre quelqu'un pour la
première fois on va demander son prénom
son nom puis rapidement vers le métier
c'est un déménageur c'est un boucher
c'est un médecin ces instituteurs orange
facile voilà on a l'impression qu'on a
connus la personne et qu'on l'a étiqueté
on l'a rangé dans la case métier mais
son job c'est pas ça qui révèle la
personne pas du tout c'est lisse et plat
jean peut en changer déjà vend plus on
lui demande jamais
quelle est ta couleur préférée son
projet de vie ce qu'il a envie de faire
ce qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils n'aiment pas
ça ça n'arrive pas tout de suite c'est
pourtant c'est avec ça qu'on découvre
les vérités d'une personne c'est
important de révéler les reliefs des
gens et les reliefs d'ailleurs alors
nous avec françois on aime bien l'art et
en arts le relief c'est très important
et un artiste c'est grâce dans une
sculpture c'est grâce au relief qu'il va
faire passer justement tout le sens la
beauté de ce qu'il a envie de révéler
même une toile une peinture c'est pas
lisse et une texture ya du relief et ça
joue sur le sens c'est très important
toi tu es comme moi tu as fait des
études d'art non tu peux nous en parler
de cette universalité du relief
oui surtout la photographie j'ai fait
des études de photographie et c'est vrai
que on apprend d'abord à changer sa
vision en regardant la vision des autres
artistes et ça me fait penser donc un
grand photographe américain du début du
19e siècle
lewis hine qui a inventé enfin qui a été
parmi les précurseurs de ce qu'on a
appelé ensuite la photographie sociale
ou la photographie documentaire aidé a
commencé sa carrière à ellis island a
photographié les migrants les migrants
qui venait comme aujourd'hui mais pour
changer de vie et qui étaient accueillis
dans dans cette île et il n'avait pas de
regard véritable oritia dit je vais je
les photographie de la façon la plus
neutre possible pour pouvoir justement
mettre en relief la vie deux de ces
personnes et sans qu'on s'aperçoit après
avec le temps c'est qu'il avait un
regard déjà qui était connotée avec
certains emprunts à l'histoire de l'art
notamment raphaël et que ce regard là
changer lui puisque quelques années
après assez rapidement d'ailleurs il
s'est investi pour lutter contre
contre le travail des enfants qui
sévissent est encore aux états unis
comme ailleurs la tu nous parles de
photos de vision de regard alors le
relief c'est le regard c'est ça pas
simplement c'est vrai que c'est ça passe
beaucoup pour ça tu as parlé tout à
l'heure de sculptures du toucher sont
tous et tous les sens en fait qu'ils
sont qui sont investis d'ailleurs le
braille l'absence l'absence de vision
fait appel à un autre sens en fait il
faut certainement pas m
le relief en case alors case cage on a
parlé la mise en cage c'est quand même
terrible c'est ça la case oui alors ça
est dit est dit durteste tout à l'heure
avec toute son énergie nous a montré ce
que c'était vraiment que d'être derrière
derrière des barreaux ils ont libéré
plusieurs fois je pense déjà une fois
physiquement bon il est sorti de prison
mais ensuite il nous a bien expliqué que
voilà il était rancourt peut-être encore
en prison
pas mal d'années et il sent libéré il
s'en libère je pensais encore
aujourd'hui avec avec son association et
j'ai une petite expérience à vous
partager avec lui puisque on a on s'est
rencontré en fait dans un endroit de
coworking en fait
spécialisée dans le numérique on
travaille ensemble souvent et eddy est
arrivé un petit peu comme moi je pense
quand j'irai de voir dans son assaut
avec n'a pas un peu dévié cognitifs ou
des idées préconçues il s'attendait à
voir des têtards sur sur des écrans ce
qu'on est aussi mais il n'y avait pas
que ça il y avait il été un peu surpris
déjà quand on est pas tous des gros
carreaux comme ça aveugle en tâtonnant
il a senti des bonnes ondes et voilà
tout un foisonnement et puis une
bienveillance en fait voilà entre midi
et deux on est parti pour déjeuner et en
fait les ordinateurs sont lissés y ait
pas de vol y a pas de compétition et ce
sont des valeurs en fait il a retrouvé
et qui partagent dans son association
aussi ses valeurs qu'on partage avec
mine de rien on fait deux mondes qui a
priori et tous sont assez différents ça
me fait penser à ce qu'on a vécu pour le
sol y campe le sol y campe ça a été
l'histoire d'une rencontre qui était a
priori
improbable le monde des professionnels
du numérique d'un côté le monde de ceux
qui luttent contre les précarités de
l'autre et puis sur un format de travail
qui s'appelle le bar quand on utilise
beaucoup nous dans le numérique on se
rencontre alors on se rencontre on vient
participer à cette réunion de travail
pour produire quelque chose pas parce
qu'on a le diplôme ou qu'on a le le le
sésame le certificat le laissez passer
et c'est non c'est juste parce qu'on a
envie d'y participer et d'être acteur de
quelque chose et donc ces deux
collectifs là se sont rencontrés parce
qu'il y avait une problématique commune
qui était comment le numérique peut
lutter contre les précarités donc ça
devrait bien ces demandes-là se
réunissent mais évidemment on était très
très motivés on avait très envie tous
deux participé ben ali quand même
quelques d'idée préconçue faut quand
même avouer et en fait ça c'est au
départ il y avait deux collectifs avec
des individus dont quelques idées
préconçues et puis parce que on a
travaillé ensemble dans une direction
commune que ça a créé un grand collectif
et ça a créé de la lawe de la richesse
et des réponses concrètes
voilà la force en fait de l'individu qui
tout seul n'est rien et qu' un mouvement
se met au service si on peut dire du
collectif on l'a vu avec avec cyril
aussi avec cyril montana qui de sa
propre histoire ses allers-retours dans
dans sa ville de lacoste se dire moment
bon c'est ma vie mais c'est pas mon
histoire c'est pas comme ça que je veux
qu'elle continue et je veux me mettre
aussi jeu fédérer les jambons etc des
histoires aussi d'abord avant tout du
maine humaine pardon et de partage qui
se passe c'est vrai mais ce sens du
collectif et cette dynamique
ça crée une c'est une force en fait et
du coup forcément on a envie de parents
de penser et de parler à côté
intelligence collective puisque on le
voit bien dès qu'on est un groupe on
parle d'intelligence collective parce
qu'on vous connaissez tous l'adage si
vous voulez partir allez vite vous
partez seul si vous voulez aller loin
repartent à plusieurs essais ça à
l'intelligence collective très bien mais
du coup là c'est un peu d'actualité
on parle hommes versus machine
des gens' collective intelligence
artificielle la date illustrant cet
officiel je la refais en articulant ce
qui n'est pas une mince affaire
donc l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement en numérique
on en est en train de nous vendre que le
cerveau ultime humain va devenir un
cerveau avec des neurones mais ce sera
des neurones synthétique est donc là
aujourd'hui il ya un chantier en cours
et un qui est en train de se faire
ratatiner par une intelligence
artificielle comme il ya quelques années
d'autres champions se faisait ratatiner
part pour pour des jeux d'échecs et
finalement si on regarde un petit peu
dans le rétroviseur qui voit-on monteil
il revient était sur un autre talk et
qu'est ce qui nous dit montaigne et bien
il nous dit l'important c'est de voyager
pour aller au devant des autres et
frottez élimé saint-servais contre celle
d'autrui
donc essayer de faire ça avec un
ordinateur ça sera pas tout à fait
évident ce que je veux dire c'est que
voilà on est encore eu et pour quelques
revenir siècle en étant optimiste on est
humain et l'humanité les idées elles ont
besoin d'aspérités elles ont besoin de
confrontations et d'aller vers l'autre
puis on a nos différences un tremble
tout à l'heure le disais on a nos
différences et c'est ce qui fait cette
richesse alors il ne s'agit pas de les
juxtaposer c'est différent cela parce
que sinon ça n'apporte rien mais si on
va effectivement utiliser nos
différences et les confronter les unes
aux autres c'est là où il ya quelque
chose qui se passe et qui se produit
c'est là où c'est magique
alors il s'agit bien de bienveillance
que si on parle juste de confrontation
si on prend par exemple le débat un
débat où il ya des idées qui s'opposent
qui n'est pas bienveillant c'est la
guerre un lien puis on repart avec une
liste d'idées qui s'opposent les unes
aux autres on en a rien appris de plus
pendant le débat et on sens inverse si
on est dans un débat où tout le monde
est d'accord très consensuel
on s'ennuie s'émousser place c'est
pareil a rien qui en ressort donc cette
confrontation bien bienveillante ces
deux là effectivement que vont être de
vraies idées et des choses qui vont se
passer et qui vont changer justement
alors
n'arrive je vous soumets mon idée et
puis vous allez l'enrichir avec vos
idées vos expériences vos avis et vous
allez avec moins on va créer ensemble
quelque chose un projet l'action et
c'est ça qui va être important et qui va
créer de la richesse de la valeur
ajoutée alors c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau et on parle aujourd'hui
d'innovation c'est une émotion oui ces
innovations alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire l'avenue passion ça se décrète pas
déjà l'innovation on va prendre un
exemple les métiers aujourd'hui dans 20
ans il va la moitié des métiers que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui auront disparu
de la même façon
la mouette la totalité des métiers que
vous trouvez c'est michel serres qui en
parle dans le petit dans la petite
planches d'illustrations du larousse des
années 50 ont disparu donc là au moins
on est tranquille il ya plus de peur ça
ose tout ça va disparaître
donc on est condamnés si on peut dire à
innover donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
innover c'est comme montaigne en fait ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que quand il dit aller vers
l'autre se frotter élimé sa cervelle que
contre celle d'autrui il donne pas un
petit mode d'emploi en dix ans alors il
faut pas les eaux sud parce que au sud
c'est pas bon on va construire un mur
d'ailleurs mais ce que je veux dire à
après ou dont il dit allez allez au
devant du chemin allez-y le chemin le
chemin c'est un signe résister c'est le
relief justement c'est l'aventuré le
chemin et c'est ça qui est bien alors
moi je propose confrontons nous les uns
aux autres confrontant nos idées
allons-y ensemble qu'est ce qu'on risque
ben on risque d'être tous ensemble de
changer le monde